let's begin with matter why does it
matter well given that everything we can
see around us is made from it the earth
beneath our feet the stars and galaxies
up in space even you and I are made from
it it's fair to say that at least to us
matter matters quite a lot it might
surprise you then to hear the only a
measly five percent of the stuff in the
universe is made from matter so what
exactly is the other 95% well that's
where things start to get a little bit
in today's episode of fun science fun
science fun science it's sort of fun
yeah let's start with a concur now in
order to spin a concur round and round
like this you have to hold the string
tightly or else it will fly away not
only then but the quicker you want to
spin it the tighter you have to hold the
string sorry makes sense right or you
could apply this same basic logic to
galaxies too for example our galaxy the
Milky Way spins around 600,000 miles an
hour so it needs to have an awful lot of
gravitational force at its center to
stop it's 100 billion stars from flying
away however here's where things start
to get weird the Milky Way actually
doesn't have enough gravitational force
to hold its stars in orbit in fact and
this is true for all of the other
galaxies in the universe
the Milky Way only has about 10% of the
force it needs to hold itself together
so what is holding it together
hey hazel you can still trying to solve
that galaxy problem why are you smiling
you want to know the answer don't try
and fool me jack this is proper science
we're doing here
yeah I know I'm a proper science person
just like you go and then try me okay
what if the reason we can't detect
what's holding the galaxies together is
because the thing that's holding them
together is get this undetectable
particles Wow
undetectable particles you don't like it
what doesn't it sound a bit like a cough
oh okay yeah maybe it does sound a bit
like a cop-out but if we're wrong who's
gonna know because they're undetectable
science and that is dark matter yes it
sounds like something that scientists
made up because they got stuck but these
undetectable particles really do exist
which we know because although we can't
see them we can see their gravitational
effects fun fact dark matter is also
referred to as weakly interacting
massive particles which if you didn't
notice abbreviates two wimps which is
kind of a mean name for scientists to
give the particles just because they
haven't been able to detect the bits but
then the question becomes will we ever
be able to find this stuff well we're
definitely trying scientists have
ventured down into caves where there's
minimal interference from other
particles to try and detect them on the
subatomic level they've even tried using
the huge particle accelerator the Large
Hadron Collider to look for them but so
far they've come up short estimates are
that we should probably be able to find
them sometime in the next ten years but
if we don't
well the scarier prospect is that we
might just have been wrong about how
gravity works this whole time
sounds like a scientific midlife crisis
waiting to happen so all of that is dark
matter which takes up about 27% of the
universe compared to normal matter which
as I said is only 5% which leaves a
whole 68 percent still unaccounted for
so what is it losing the title now maybe
you're already aware of this but right
now the universe is expanding this
expansion started with the Big Bang
13.8 billion years ago and it's just
kept on going ever since now what you
might expect to happen here is for the
universe to keep expanding at the same
rate forever and ever or for it to
eventually come to a stop but in fact
what's happening is the universe is
expanding faster and faster and just
like how galaxies don't have enough
gravitational force on their own this
accelerated expansion of the universe
just doesn't make any sense there has to
be some kind of energy causing it but
scientists haven't been able to detect
any so what did they do you guessed it
they decided the cause was some kind of
undetectable energy and they named it
the slight dark energy so what do we
know about this stuff well the current
scientific consensus is yep that's right
this stuff is even more elusive than
dark matter well there are a few
different explanations floating around
for what it is right now no one's really
sure so if you ever hear someone saying
all those scientists think they know
everything just tell them that as far as
95 percent of the universe's concerns
they haven't even been able to find it
yet thanks for watching also big thank
you to by friends Jack and hazel for
being in this video do please go and
give them a subscribe this Christmas I
have 4 more of these fun science videos
on the way to you so do please stay
tuned for those each one is inspired by
part of my book oh look a LAN seemless
it's in bookstores now if you want a
copy I'll put some links down in the
description for places you can buy it if
you want to no pressure or anything ok
thanks for watching bye mine you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool